traditional male leadership qualities
are things like decisiveness,
aggression, you know,
those kinds of things.
traditional female
qualities are things like patience,
you know, maternal instinct, empathy.
and I think the mistake we've made across all
leadership is we teach male leadership,
we teach decisiveness, and we teach aggression.
and these are the things we teach,
and we teach that to everybody.
and the reality is,
what makes great leaders is they have a balance.
and what we should be teaching is more
of female leadership.
and, you know,
all leaders
should take on the qualities of patience and empathy.
you know, this is the irony.